[Musica]
Ciao a tutti è bello vedervi qua e siamo
qui per
raccontarvi la favola mia parto proprio
da una canzone di Renato Zero vi
racconto la favola mia al racconto ogni
giorno chiunque tu sia E mi vesto di
sogno per darti se vuoi
l'illusione di un bimbo che gioca agli
eroi
Io sono
come mi vedete perché da bambino sono
cresciuto con Heidi il cartone animato
per me top perché parlava della montagna
sono i piedi delle Tofane
Nell'ultimo periodo ho avuto il piacere
di superarle diverse volte
Ed è stato bello perché da bambino io
ero il bimbo tremendo che andava in
montagna con mamma e papà
ed ero sempre davanti e non mi beccavano
mai
scappato via dai Sono un po' pazzerello
concedetemi ero già birbo piccolo prima
poi una volta è successo un
inconveniente tecnico se vogliamo dirlo
così si chiama incidenti una colpa a
nessuno
mi sono trovato a rallentare la mia
camminata il mio passo
e stando disteso su un letto d'ospedale
è aumentato il pensiero
però perdere una gamba non vuol dire
perdere la vita
quindi è stata una fonte di stimolo
per cercare di ritornare a camminare nei
monti non quei sentieri dei Monti
ci sono riuscito abbiamo ripreso insieme
alla mia attuale compagna Antonella
Siamo tornati a fare il giro delle Tre
Cime di Lavaredo
e quello è stato lo Start up per me per
capire che le mie paure possono essere
sconfitte
non è stato semplice
dopo 6 anni di stop totale
tutti i periodi di riabilitazione che ho
subito per tornare lì
è stato fantastico
meraviglioso Visto che stiamo parlando
di un Tex meraviglia
quello è stato lo Start up per me per
capire che potevo sfidare le mie paure
ancora e ancora e ancora è tutt'oggi
continuo a sfidarle
è una questione di
non chiudersi a riccio ma di aprirsi
verso la casualità verso le occasioni
che la vita ti propone ho cominciato a
fare ad assecondare delle proposte di
amici che mi invitavano ad andare a
camminare lungo i sentieri della
montagna Il sentiero mai cominciarono a
essermi stretti Cercavo qualcosa di più
grande più impegnativo per mettere me
stesso il mio la mia mente alla prova
e gradualmente Ho trasformato la sfida
sportiva in sfide di vita
e ogni volta che mi mettevo in
competizione con me stesso
cercavo di superare
Lo scalino che avevo davanti che era
disegnato nella mia mente da me non
dagli altri
è chiaro a tutti Spero che molto spesso
i problemi gli scalini della vita ce li
creiamo noi
Quindi dobbiamo cercare in qualche
maniera
di viverla anche se ci sono delle
problematiche visto il mio caso paure
che ti vincolano e ti bloccano molte
persone prima di riuscire a dire sì
Moreno pesce puoi fare le Vertical
ci hanno pensato
però mi hanno accettato per quello che
ero hanno cominciato a conoscermi le
Vertical sono dei traini impegnativi che
si sviluppano una distanza massima di 5
km ma con dislivello minimo 1000 metri
vi assicuro che recentemente il mio Best
Time è un'ora e 44 sui 1000 metri di
dislivello e un chilometro e 8 di
sviluppo
questo posso fare così
però non è non è questo non è questo che
vi sto raccontando ragazzi voglio
raccontarvi di un'altra cosa voglio
raccontarvi che la vita mi ha messo in
condizioni di avere fortuna molta
fortuna se io non facevo quell'incidente
Oggi non ero qui e non trovavo non
conoscevo certe persone tra le quali la
mia guida liotenesche in primis un mio
amico
un giorno mi disse
incontrato per caso la prima volta che
vede Moreno pesce Vorrei accompagnarti
in grande
e io lì ho detto
Ma come Cosa vuol dire
Non ho capito
me lo puoi ripetere
Voglio accompagnarti sulla cima grande
di Lavaredo forse si vedono da qua Forse
indietro bene Da lì è cominciato un
percorso di formazione Perché io avevo
paura da normodotato della corda
dell'arrampicata ed invece con l'io sono
riuscito ad aprirmi
ad accettare di andare piano di portare
pazienza di prendere anche qualche
insolenza
ma comunque di riuscire ad arrivare in
un punto che mai Avrei potuto
immaginare quando ero disteso nel letto
d'ospedale dopo 34 sacche di sangue dopo
11 giorni di rianimazione con mio papà
che mi guarda tutto a posto Pippo è
tutto a posto Guarda che bestia c'è qua
adesso
è stata una sfida nella sfida
Abbiamo cominciato ad allenarci con Dio
per andare a raggiungere Questo
obiettivo
è un giorno non ce la facevo più tutte
le mattine aprire una finestra o la
porta mi vedevo la treccine davanti casa
Caspita
Sì ma dobbiamo aspettare fotografo
dobbiamo aspettare videomaker perché
è giusto è giusto
ripeto ancora È giusto far vedere queste
cose per stimolare altre persone come me
a muoversi dai Divani e vincere la
vergogna di uscire da casa e mostrarsi
con questo pezzo di ferro su
è chiaro
nel contesto nel contesto della vita io
sono così adesso i miei genitori
mi accettano così la mia bambina mi fa
le treccine però i miei obiettivi sono
obiettivi come quelli di chiunque altro
devo solo avere la possibilità di
trovare delle persone che mi permettono
di raggiungerli con la mia guida e altre
persone
adesso non sono più il solo adesso c'è
un movimento di persone amputate che
cammina in montagna che viene con me
recentemente abbiamo fatto delle belle
cose anche qui a Cortina nel Cadore
ma raggiungere la vetta della grande è
stato un percorso formativo tra me e io
che mi ha permesso di creare un cordone
ombelicale con la mia guida
E lì ho imparato ad accettare che questa
cosa non è un superuomo che la sta
facendo ma la può fare chiunque chiunque
di voi può prendersi una guida e
mettersi in gioco è un disabile lo può
fare a maggior ragione per vincere le
sfide della vita perché qualcosa gli è
stato tolto dalla vita
e non è che perché qualcosa è stata
tolta si blocca tutto
se voi pensate
ci abbiamo messo 16 ore 6 ore a salire
10 a scendere perché c'era traffico
c'erano sassi c'era gente che andava
senza guida e si perdeva
noi dobbiamo puntare a fare anche
sicurezza così come sono io punto a fare
sicurezza per cercare di sensibilizzare
la gente ad andare con le guide
e avere un attimo di
Self Control
e quando la giornata è storta
sapere che siamo noi a colorarla
voi adesso forse ridete
Ma voi avete due piedi e decidete Con
quale piede scendere Io ne ho uno solo
quindi alla mattina il colore della
giornata Dipende da come metto giù il
piede Siccome il piede c'è solo destro
così è E così sarà
quindi non è che sia qui
a raccontare cosa io ho visto
raccontando che
una vita di rivincita di rivincita di
Sfide
dove molto spesso mi faccio male mi
gratto le mani perdo anche sangue
e mi affido completamente
corpo e anima a Lio e alla corda quella
corda che mi tira Mi trascina mi porta a
destra a sinistra ma che comunque mi dà
sicurezza e quelli sicurezza mi aiuta a
superare le mie paure le stesse paure
che avete voi quando dovete prendere una
decisione non è scritto da nessuna parte
che è quella giusta
però quando vi porta a termine e a
vincerla
tornate dalle cariche sorridete
avete un qualcosa un qualcosa di bello
in più
da far vedere e mi sembra che
tutta questa cosa a me l'ha insegnata
una montagna meravigliosa che ho davanti
o dietro questo quadro senza cornice è
spettacolare
Buona vita a tutti ragazzi
[Applauso]